NEIGHBORS TO THE NORTH CLEARLY
LOSING IT PRIME MINISTER WHO
NEEDS A HISTORY LESSON.
DECLARED WAR ON CANADIAN
CITIZENS LIKE THEY ARE ISIS
CALIPHATE.
EMERGENCY POWERS, FREEZING BANK
ACCOUNTS AND THREATENING TO TAKE
AWAY PROTESTERS' DOGS AND
CHILDREN.
DANA PERINO IS VERY UPSET.
GETTING SO BAD UP THERE.
GOVERNMENT FORCES ARE EVEN
TARGETING INNOCENT GELATO SHOPS
LIKE THIS ONE HERE IN OTTAWA,
CANADA.
TURNS OUT, THE OWNER OF STELLA
LUNA CAFE MADE A GIANT MISTAKE.
SHE PRIVATESLY SUPPORTED THE
FREEDOM TRUCKERS' CONVOY WITH A
$250 DONATION.
HER DONATION THEN LEAKED AND WAS
MADE PUBLIC.
HER GELATO SHOP WAS DOXXED AND
BEGAN RECEIVING THREATS,
LUNATICS THREATENING HER WITH
VIOLENCE AND VANDALISM.
TREATING HER LIKE A SALEM WITCH
ALL BECAUSE SHE SHOWED HER
SUPPORT FOR FREEDOM.
THE OWNER OF STELLA LUNA GELATO
CAFE.
GIULIANI, NO RELATION TO RUDE IS
HERE NOW.
WHAT'S GOING ON UP THERE WITH
YOUR SHOP?
>> WELL,' I SHOULD PREFACE TO
SAY I HAVE A TENDENCY TO THINK
WITH MY HEART AND NOT WITH MY
HEAD.
DOES THAT GET ME IN TROUBLE?
A LOT.
WOULD I THAT I THINK THAT ABOUT
MYSELF?
NOT IN A MILLION YEARS.
AND WHEN I HEARD WITH A GROUP OF
PEOPLE WHO WERE WILLING TO DRIVE
ALL THE WAY ACROSS THE COUNTRY
IN BELOW 30 WEATHER TO GATHER
PEACEFULLY IN FRONT OF
PARLIAMENT AND STAND UP FOR
THEIR BELIEVES.
INSTEAD OF MANDATING EXISTENCE
OUT OF EVERYONE NEEDS TO BE
REVISITED MY HEART SAYS NO.
I DON'T THINK ANYONE AND I
CERTAINLY DON'T THINK ANYONE
WOULD HAVE IMAGINED THAT IT
WOULD HAVE TRANSFORMED INTO
SOMETHING HIKE WE ARE WITNESSING
TODAY.
>> Jesse: WE ARE WITNESSING
COMPLETE CHAOS AND I DON'T KNOW
HOW TO DESCRIBE IT BUT YOU
PROBABLY KNOW BETTER THAN I DO
SINCE YOU ARE UP THERE.
WHAT'S BEEN THE BLOW BACK FOR
YOU AND YOUR SHOP AND WHAT KIND
OF THREATS AND HARASSMENT HAVE
YOU FACED AFTER THAT DONATION
WAS MADE PUBLIC.
>> YOU NEED TO UNDERSTAND THAT
STELLA LUNA IS OUR LIVELIHOOD.
MY HUSBAND AND OUR CHILDREN AND
SON-IN-LAW ALL WORK FOR THE
BUSINESS.
IT'S HOW WE PAY OUR RENT AND HOW
WE KEEP OUR LIGHTS ON AND HOW WE
EAT.
SO, WE HAVE FEEL VERY
PASSIONATELY ABOUT EATING.
AND.
>> Jesse: THAT --
>> -- EVERYONE HAS PUSHED HARD
TRYING TO KEEP THIS BUSINESS
ALIVE.
SO WE HAVE THIS -- THE PASSION
AND IT JUST KEEPS GOING ON AND
ON I REACHED INTO MY PERSONAL
POCKET AND I PULLED OUT 250
BUCKS OF MY PERSONAL MONEY AND I
GAVE A DONATION TO FILL A GAS
TANK OF SOMEONE SO THEY DIDN'T
HAVE TO SLEEP IN MINUS 30 IN THE
COLD THAT NIGHT.
I THINK THAT DECISION SPEAKS TO
MY HUMANITY AND NOT TO POLITICAL
BELIEFS.
BUT ATTACKING OUR CHILDREN,
ATTACKING OUR TEEN, THAT'S
UNCONSCIONABLE.
AND I THINK NEVER IN MY 56 YEARS
I HAVE EVER EXPERIENCED A
COUNTRY SO DIVIDED, SO FULL OF
HATRED TOWARDS FRIENDS AND
NEIGHBORHOODS, SORRY I LOST YOU
THERE.
SO FULL OF HATRED TOWARDS
FRIENDS AND NEIGHBORS.
YOU KNOW, THEY MIGHT HAVE
OPINIONS THAT DIFFER FROM
THEIRS.
BUT THEY ARE STILL WILLING TO
PUBLICLY SHAME AND HUMILIATE AND
VIEW ANGRY VITRIOL.
WE HAVE BEEN CALLED TERRORISTS
FOR THE FIRST 36 HOURS.
WE WERE INUNDATED WITH HATRED,
WITH THREATS OF VIOLENCE.
PEOPLE THREATENED OUR TEAM ON
THE PHONE TELLING THEM WE ARE
COMING TO GET YOU.
WE ARE GOING TO GO BRICKS
THROUGH YOUR WINDOW.
YOU WILL PAY FOR THIS YOU NASA
IS I SUPPORTER.
I HAVE BEEN CALLED A DISGUSTING
PIG OF A WOMAN I SHOULD ROT IN
HELL.
OUR RURAL SHOP OUT IN ONTARIO
SOMEONE DRAPED A LARGE BED SHEET
OVER OUR SIGN, I'M SORRY.
IT'S BEEN A TOUGH FEW DAYS.
AND THE SIGN READ TAMMY SUPPORTS
TERRORISTS.
NOW, MAMA BEAR IS GOING TO DIG
OUT HER CLAWS ON THAT ONE.
WE ARE GETTING THE VIDEO
SURVEILLANCE OF THE INCIDENT AND
WE WILL PURSUE THAT WITH THE
POLICE.
BUT LATE YESTERDAY AFTERNOON,
MESSAGES OF SUPPORT AND
ENCOURAGEMENT STARTED TO ARRIVE
AND PEOPLE FROM COAST TO COAST
TO COAST THROUGHOUT CANADA AND
THE U.S. AND, YOU KNOW,
[INAUDIBLE] ONLINE AND CALLING
THEMSELVES GUARDIAN ANGELS.
SO, YOU KNOW, WE'RE GOING TO USE
THOSE FUNDS TO HELP PAY THE
STAFF FOR THEIR MISSED SHIFTS
AND GET SOME SECURITY GUARDS IN
AND MAKE SURE EVERYBODY IS SAFE
AND THAT THEY FEEL SAFE COMING
TO WORK.
BUT THE PHONE HAS BEEN RINGING
OFF THE HOOK ALL DAY TODAY FROM
CALLS ALL OVER CANADA, ALL OVER
THE U.S., SHARING STORIES OF
LOSING THEIR JOBS BECAUSE OF
BANKRUPTCY OR BECAUSE THEY
REFUSED TO GET VACCINATED.
LOSING THEIR HOME, WE HAVE HEARD
TRAGIC STORIES.
I DIDN'T THINK IT WAS GOING TO
BE THIS HARD.
ING.
>> Jesse: I UNDERSTAND.
>> YOU KNOW, WE HAVE HEARD SO
MANY STORIES FROM PEOPLE CALLING
TO SUPPORT US BECAUSE, YOU KNOW,
WE'RE PRETTY INSIGNIFICANT AND
WE'RE JUST A LITTLE GELATO SHOP.
AND ALL WE WANT TO DO IS MAKE
REALLY GOOD GELATO A